You're officially invited to the wedding
of Brooke and Joseph Cavanaugh.
Holy crap, this season of
"American Horror Story" is -
don't say it, Think Story, don't jinx it -
one of the best yet?
Yes, I am absolutely loving the mystery
and 80's nostalgia AHS is pumping out.
And this episode is filled with so
many tinfoil hat conspiracy theories,
I feel like I'm in a Shyamalan movie.
So we're gonna get right into it.
And before we start, make sure to
like and subscribe with the bell on
for the latest
"American Horror Story" updates.
Episode 2 begins with
the arrival of Dr. Hopple.
If you listen to the ominous
synthesizer music in the background,
which I can't really play
or I'll get demonetized,
you'll notice it's a throwback to John
Carpenter's score for "Halloween".
She walks past the payphone Brooke
answered at the end of last episode.
The same phone where someone
answered, saying they were Satan.
Last episode also ended with the Night
Stalker coming out from the forest near Brooke,
but we never saw Brooke acknowledge
him, so he's still biding his time.
Hopple stops in front of the Camp Redwood map
and seems to point to this area near the bottom,
likely where the main camp is situated,
before she invites herself
into Margaret Booth's cabin.
And for someone who is a Christian,
Margaret isn't too welcoming.
This is oddly juxtaposed later in the episode
when the Night Stalker literally breaks into the
cabin and she welcomes him with open arms. Weird.
Hopple tries to convince
Margaret to shut down the camp
due to the recent escape of
Benjamin Richter aka Mr Jingles,
who is likely coming for her.
After all, he apparently has an
obsessive revenge fantasy to kill Margaret,
the lone survivor of the Camp
Redwood massacre 14 years ago.
Margaret shows her she's
prepared, taking out a handgun,
and you know whenever they show a gun,
it will almost inevitably be used later on.
I also found it a bit suspicious for a camp leader, someone who is around children all day, to own a gun.
And also considering she
thinks Jingles is locked away.
Then again, this is
"American Horror Story".
Margaret refuses to
budge and Hopple storms off
only to have her tire torn to shreds by this
nasty-looking thing, planted here by Mr. Jingles.
He's still riding in Roy's truck,
which he stole in episode 1
and ends up killing her, saying,
And slices off her ear.
Now, this is the first time we've actually
seen him do this since the escape.
We never saw it with the
orderly or Ed from the gas station.
This either means it was simply never shown
or that he only takes ears from certain people.
Remember that Hopple is - ahem - or was the
chief psychologist at Red Meadows Asylum
where Jingles was kept.
She likely was in charge of
administering any treatment to him.
And if Hopple was, say, doing illegal
experiments or therapies on him,
which we see in the
season preview video,
she'd have an ulterior
motive to stop Jingles.
Jingles may be the only one who knows the
truth about what is really happening at that asylum.
This would mean Jingles killing Hopple
wasn't just a random cold-blooded murder,
it was revenge for years of torture.
While the other counselors party it
up, Brooke is fixated on the television,
which reports the
murder at Roy's gas station.
The sheriff himself isn't sure if this murder is any way associated with the string of murders happening in L.A.,
the ones by the Night Stalker.
Now, I didn't mention
this in my last video,
but he is based off real-life
serial killer Ricky Ramirez,
who terrorized L.A. and San Francisco with a string of home invasion murders from June 1984 to August 1985,
in which he was convicted of 13.
When Brooke expresses her concerns,
the others seem more interested in the
"Where's the beef?" commercial than her plight.
"Hey, where's the beef?"
But before anything can happen, Margaret
interrupts, telling them it's all time for bed.
And we get my favorite line of the episode:
We get more religious talk from Margaret about how this place is used to cleanse the soul and wash away the sin.
It's usually the religious zealots who
are willing to take things too extreme,
so all this talk about "cleansing the
soul" raises major red flags to me.
Speaking of which, a literal
red flag right outside her cabin.
Montana tries to console Brooke by
comparing her almost getting killed to fat camp.
"It's a fat camp!"
And even though Montana isn't the best at
this, we know her heart is in the right place.
This line here is very interesting and makes
us even doubt if Brooke is telling the truth.
Up until this point, no one
else has seen the Night Stalker.
But he is real, since we later see him chat
with Margaret and fight with Mr. Jingles.
And yes, I'm still holding onto the theory that there
is more to Mr. Jingles than meets the eye - or ear.
We then get my favorite scene of
the episode: American Red Wedding.
Yes, Brooke was set to be married,
when her jealous husband-to-be brutally murders the best man and her dad, thinking Brooke cheated on him.
But Brooke, having a terrible fear of the
dark, just wanted someone to be there,
since she didn't want to see her
husband the same day of the wedding.
This is why I have gamophobia:
fear of marriage.
Kidding, I'm single.
DM me, I'm so terribly alone.
Back in 1984, Brooke
reiterates that she never cheated,
and maybe it was her sense of vulnerability or
the fact Montana had a bunch of Pabst Blue Ribbons,
she goes in for the kiss, which
Brooke doesn't take too well.
It's shower time!
"Let's go take hot shower!"
And we get these creepy voyeur shots of the boys,
which is totally reminiscent of 70's and 80's horror.
Trevor tells the guys what he was
up to with Montana last episode
when Xavier runs
off to grab a towel.
Margaret turns off the power in what
I'm assuming is mandatory bedtime,
judging by how
she checks her watch.
She's the only one who has the key
here, which might come into play later on.
Xavier is grabbed by a porn producer in the
forest at night, a line you really never want to hear.
His name is Blake, who
we'll come to know as daddy.
"What the hell, daddy?"
It looks like I have some competition.
Daddy loves you very much.
Blake is obsessed with Xavier,
comparing him to a Rembrandt painting.
For his help in getting him clean, Blake coerced Xavier
to do a gay porno, which he now uses as blackmail,
blackmail which could completely destroy
his chances of becoming a famous star.
But Xavier sees a way out.
If he can offer Blake something better,
a man even bigger than John Holmes,
a porn star known for his, ahem,
endowment, he could be scot-free.
And there just so happens to be
a guy like that at Camp Redwood.
In the shower Chet can't seem
to take his eyes off the prize.
This might also be the fact
that he's been taking steroids,
and we know what kind of
effect that can have down there.
"It shrinks?"
Our favorite porn producer Blake also
can't seem to take his eyes off Trevor,
getting him killed in the process.
Notice how we see Mr. Jingles'
leather gloves here, but nothing else.
It's entirely possible that this isn't Mr.
Jingles at all, rather one of his copycats.
In my season to come preview video, I noted how
we'll eventually come to see multiple Mr. Jingles',
and that Margaret herself could
be posing as Jingles as well.
Remember she did just turn off the lights, carries
a bunch of keys on her, and hates those who sin.
And Blake is a prime candidate.
At the docks, Brooke gets some
fresh air after her kiss with Montana,
and comes across
Hopple's floating corpse.
But look at this, if we compare the shot from episode 2 to the one we saw in the season preview video,
they are very different.
Now, this is either just a
mistake on the part of AHS,
or it's hinting that what Brooke is seeing may
not be real, or at least not the way she sees it.
It's possible we could see this same
event replayed in the later episode,
but from a different
perspective or with new information.
I have a theory I'm gonna talk about a
little bit later that could also fit into this.
She's interrupted by the Night Stalker, but is
able to escape. But let's hold on for a second.
Brooke isn't stabbed
by the Night Stalker here,
but in the season to come video
when she's being chased by him,
you can clearly see a
stab wound on her shoulder.
Now there could be an explanation for this.
It's possible this could happen in a later episode.
But it's when the Night Stalker bumps into the
hiker that we really need to get our tinfoil hats on.
Also, can we just take a moment to acknowledge
that the hiker has a habit of bumping into things?
Moving along, the hiker
says two important things:
"You're not supposed to be here" and,
most telling, "Wait, I don't die here".
And this is interesting,
because in the preview video,
we see him getting knocked
out, possibly killed by Mr. Jingles.
What does this mean?
Well, there's a theory out there that everyone
at the camp in 1984 is a method actor,
preparing for their roles in an upcoming
film about the original massacre.
They are all staying in character and following
a series of events to better get into their roles.
In episode 1, Xavier even says he's trained under Stella Adler, who was known for pioneering method acting,
an acting technique in which the
actor does not break character.
In the earlier preview clips that FX released,
we also see the characters doing a screen
test and hitting marks on the cabin floor.
This would mean that those grainy shots we've
seen that I previously said indicate a flashback
might not be flashbacks at all, rather
actual film footage from the shoot.
But it seems as though the Night
Stalker, according to the hiker,
is not a part of this acting exercise,
as he literally guts the hiker.
We'll get back to the hiker in a bit.
Rita's in a nursing station, putting away stuff
in the middle of the night when the power is out,
because I guess that's what you do,
when she's confronted by Mr. Jingles.
This confrontation, however, we never
see, which I think is very important.
Now if things couldn't get any weirder, we
have Brooke trying to call the police to no avail,
when an apparent clone of the hiker appears,
only to be killed again by the Night Stalker.
This guy isn't having a good time.
But the Stalker takes the counselor's
badge to see he's from the 1970's.
And check out his name, which is an anagram
for Jason Voorhees, the killer in "Friday the 13th".
The Stalker seems to be freaked out by his
apparent return and heads off into the forest.
Ray yells as everyone congregates
around the dead body of Blake.
And you know, they have to check he's
actually dead by poking him with a stick.
They hear the clanging of Mr. Jingles'
keys and run off towards the van,
which directly transitions us to
another pair of keys held by Margaret.
But more interesting here
is her holding a bottle of wine.
Was she with someone, is she celebrating
something, or does she just need a nightcap?
It's a conscious decision to show her with
this bottle, so expect it to come back later.
Waiting for her is the Night Stalker, who
wants to know more about the hiker.
You and me both, Ricky. You and me both.
And for a guy who says he's the son of
Satan, Margaret is surprisingly helpful,
curious about him.
For Margaret, Ricky is a lost
soul, someone who can be saved.
She tells him that
So we're supposed to believe
Jesus brought back the hiker.
But something tells me
there's a better answer out there.
Margaret asked Ricky what the worst
thing that ever happened to him was,
making this the fourth time in this episode alone
where characters have divulged their biggest trauma.
First being Montana getting
felt up outside of Sam Goody's,
second Brooke on her wedding,
third Xavier and his drug/porn past,
and finally Ricky's childhood.
As a kid, Ricky's mother inhaled poisonous
fumes while she was pregnant at the boot factory.
He had abusive parents, was knocked in the back of
the head by a swing, causing him to have seizures,
and was exposed to gruesome real-life photos
of people his cousin Mike killed in Vietnam.
Although this could be completely unrelated,
both Jingles and Miriam Mead's father
in "Apocalypse" killed many in Vietnam.
At 13, Ricky was present when Mike
shot his wife in a domestic dispute
All of this is based off Ricky
Ramirez's real-life upbringing.
For Ricky, pain is all he
has known - that and feet.
Margaret tells him he doesn't have
to feel bad about what he's done.
This sounds a lot like Margaret trying
to justify something she did in the past,
but she goes on to say that in order to achieve
freedom from this pain, you need two things:
God and trauma.
So she agrees to look into the hiker if he
hunts down Mr. Jingles and leaves the rest alone.
She's basically using him to get to Jingles.
The counselors decide to get the hell
out of dodge by getting into Xavier's van.
And why are they letting Xavier drive
again? Did they learn nothing last episode?
Notice here this cigarette brand Brezza,
which is a common prop name for
a cigarette brand used in film and television
and can be seen in shows like
"Lost" and FX's own "You're the Worst".
This is either AHS using it as a prop,
or if we go with the "This is a movie"
narrative, it could be a prop on a set.
The van ends up crashing into
Margaret's after narrowly missing Rita,
who apparently escaped
that attack from Mr. Jingles.
Interesting.
Also, where is Chef Bertie?
With the only chance of escape
Rita's car and Trevor's motorcycle,
a motorcycle we see in the
previews taking off as Jingles watches,
the group decides to split up,
because it wouldn't be a
horror show unless they split up.
Margaret ends up finding the hiker in the
woods, and there is a lot of fun stuff to unpack here.
First, he says that Margaret looks "so
different", which could mean two things:
A, she's just changed a lot in 14 years,
or B, if you believe these are all actors, that the
Margaret here is an actress playing the real Margaret.
One of the first things Margaret asks, which I find rather suspicious, is what he saw the night of the massacre.
If Margaret was the actual killer,
the hiker could possibly be the only one
who knows the truth aside from Mr. Jingles.
It appears that the hiker did see Margaret
the night of the murder, but only the aftermath.
He never saw her committing the actual act.
He ran away, only to be
killed, supposedly, by Jingles.
Now, two things could
have happened here:
Margaret told Jingles
that the hiker was the killer,
and Jingles went after him only
for Margaret to frame him later,
or that Margaret herself dressed
up as Jingles and killed the hiker.
After all, the hiker said he only
heard the keys of Mr. Jingles.
This whole thing of the hiker being unjustly killed could explain why his ghost has remained at Camp Redwood.
AHS is no stranger to having ghost
characters with unfinished business.
This can be seen heavily in
season one's "Murder House".
Brooke Ray, Chet and
Rita check out the infirmary
while Trevor, Xavier and
Montana head back to the cabins.
Xavier totally breaks down
saying everything is his fault,
when the episode ends while two
figures bang simultaneously on both doors.
We do see the Night Stalker head
toward the infirmary and a few shots prior,
we see Jingles outside near the
cabins where Montana and Xavier are.
We also know Margaret is somewhere in the woods
with the hiker, and Chef Bertie is nowhere to be found.
You basically have a 1 in 4
chance of guessing who it could be,
unless, of course, we have a 5th unknown
new character banging on the door.
Remember the newscasts reported the murder
at Roy's gas station just a few hours ago,
so it's possible we could get a sheriff or
detective working their way to Camp Redwood,
seeing as the counselors were one of the last
people to see Patrick Swayze's brother alive.
This episode was chock-full of new
developments, but left us with even more mystery.
I want to hear your theories below, or you can
reach out to me on Twitter @ThinkStoryYT.
Make sure to like and subscribe
and check out my other AHS videos.
I'm here all season and I'll
see you next week for episode 3.
Until next time remember,
"What the hell, daddy"
No! Daddy loves you very much.